November is here and with a new month
comes a ton of new video games and this
week is home to a very anticipated
sequel that's Dishonored 2 this time
around you can play as corvo attano or
his daughter Emily each one has his own
set of abilities but both are out to
reclaim the throne in the coastal city
of car naka your decisions don't end
with choosing which character you'll use
as every mission is wide open for you to
take a stealthy or guns blazing approach
you can play as you see fit when
Dishonored 2 releases on November 11th
if you'd rather choose virtual reality
PlayStation VR is getting Eagle flight
it's one part post-apocalypse and one
part flight simulator the VR game lets
you control an eagle as it soars over
Paris 50 years after humans disappear
and nature reclaims the city you can
dive under bridges soar through narrow
alleys and even battle other birds and
multiplayer dogfights or will they
technically be Bird fights either way
that's out on the 8th let's return to
Earth for a moment with harvest moon Sky
Tree Village the latest in the cutesy
farming series lets you tend your crops
get married and start a family like
usual but this one also tasks you with
restoring the Lost Sky Tree Village to
do this you'll need to help the seven
legendary sky trees flourish and bring
prosperity back to the land you can
embark on this quest on your nintendo
3ds november eight if you prefer the
sword fighting world of high fantasy to
peaceful farms then you might like
tyranny the new RPG from obsidian a
rebellion has risen in the land of tears
and the powerful fate binder is set to
handle the situation you'll take on the
role of this fate binder acting as judge
jury and executioner as you make world
changing decisions complete quests and
grows stronger the journey begins on PC
on the 10
if you're in the market for a new
console you're in luck Sony's
PlayStation 4 pro takes the console
generation a step forward with enhanced
graphics 4k and HDR support and faster
processing and frame rates all current
ps4 games will work with the new system
and a bunch of them are getting updated
to look prettier and run better if you
want to upgrade or if you want your
first ps4 to be the fanciest you can
pick one up on the 10th and those are
the heavy hitters for this week as
always please remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change we'll see you guys
back here next time